à des pourparlers qui s'annonce
compliquée les etats unis la russie ont
entamé à genève leurs discussions pour
désamorcer la crise en ukraine avant
même le début de la réunion les deux
parties se sont fermement positionnés si
washington a prévenu d'un risque de
confrontation moscou a exclu toute
concession pour protéger le pays d'une
potentielle agressions des pays membres
de l'otan la russie veut récupérer les
zones tampons perdu après l'effondrement
de l'union soviétique allait précision
avec notre envoyée spéciale à genève
habib marosi
cette journée de négociations a été
précédée hier soir par un dîner entre
saga et riabkov et wendy sherman les
numéros deux des diplomaties russe et
américaine
hier soir le chef de la délégation russe
a déclaré que la russie souhaitait
tester la capacité de washington à
prendre des décisions responsables
l'objectif premier des négociations
d'aujourd'hui était initialement de
discuter de désarmement nucléaire et de
l' équilibre entre les deux puissances
atomiques que sont les états unis et la
russie sauf que sauf que depuis la crise
ukrainienne a totalement phagocyter
l'ordre du jour des discussions et les
déclarations de ces derniers jours et
semaines n'augurait rien de bon cela
fait des mois que washington et moscou
sont à couteaux tirés sur ce dossier
ukrainien et jusqu'à présent personne ne
semblait prêt à céder le moindre pouce
de terrain écoutez ce que disait le chef
de la diplomatie américaine il y à peu
la russie exige maintenant que les états
unis et l'otan signe des traités pour
retirer les forces de l'otan stationnés
sur le territoire des alliés en europe
centrale et orientale et pour interdire
à l'ukraine d'adhérer un jour à l'otan
ils veulent nous entraîner dans un débat
sur l'otan plutôt que de se concentrer
sur la question qui nous occupe à savoir
leur agression contre l'ukraine
avait même déclaré que la délégation
russe ne discuterait pas des mesures de
désescalade demandées par washington et
l'otan à la frontière ukrainienne le ton
des négociations semblaient hier soir
s'être cependant un tout petit peu
apaisées reste à savoir sur quels points
exactement russes et américains sont
prêts à faire des concessions